joining me is the singer and songwriter
Billy Bragg musicians socialist activist
good to have you on on May Day and uh
let's just start with clearing up one
thing Billy your position on the
monarchy you don't want to abolish it is
that right but you think you it needs to
be changed
yeah I'd like us I'd like a ceremonial
monarchy I'd like them to be available
for opening your local school your local
whatever
um you know out on the balcony on high
days and holidays and mostly funding
themselves maybe not so many people in
the royal family official and a few less
palaces so yeah basically out of the
Constitution really I don't think they
should be part of our constitution I
think the the British people should be
Sovereign in their Parliament rather
than the Crown so that's that kind of
sums out for me it's ceremonial monarchy
yeah and I you met the queen at least
once I think I read that you met her and
uh you said she Charmed the pants off me
um do you think the respects for the
late Queen which let's be honest many
people had will necessarily translate
into respect for King Charles
I think that's going to be very
difficult for that because I think the
thing about the queen was she was
essentially unknowable she kept to that
idea that she shouldn't really say
anything that was well really anything
at all really unfortunately with Charles
we've kind of known him for the last
what is he 74 75 years we know his
personality and I think the real danger
to the monarchy doesn't come from
republicanism it comes from a politics
um that's kind of descending into a
culture war and I think those on the
right who object to people talking about
Britain's role in slavery and those kind
of things will find it very difficult to
support Charles if he does make the
monarchy more inclusive if he does seek
to address these issues that obviously
are on his mind and what about though
that Charles I guess there will be some
who think he has earned respect you know
he was talking about the environment and
climate change before you know the term
global warming had been coined um the
prince's trust does all this work for
you know young kids who are struggling
oh yeah I mean I think that's great that
they do these these positive things and
it it does allow uh different ideas to
come into the the mainstream but as I
say I think if they begin you know
suppose a royal family become woke what
do you think the Daily Telegraph we're
going to say about that they'll go after
him and you've seen uh they can go after
someone the way they've uh they've
treated Prince Harry so I think that's
where the real danger comes rather from
any kind of Republican movement yeah and
this idea that's uh you know that the
public will be given the chance to pay
homage
To The King by vocally offering their uh
true Allegiance is what it said I mean
do you think that's a good idea or is it
a high risk strategy do you think well I
I think it's a higher risk strategy I
mean today as you already mentioned Mark
today is May Day now you know some of us
celebrate my dad as International
workers day but if we set out to say
that people are asked to you know fly a
red flag today or expected to fly a red
flag everybody would rightly say well
that's not how I feel why should I have
to do that and I think that's the same
thing with this homage I mean homage it
seems to me the whole thing kind of
smacks to me like something out a Game
of Thrones rather than some out of a
modern democracy so I think it probably
would have been better if they just
if I just did it like um like songs of
praise like you know they put the words
up for and if you want to sing along you
can sing along if you don't well you
know you can do something else make a
cup of tea look out the window you know
I think I saying that they're you know
asking people to do it I think that's
that steps over the mark a little bit
and I think it prods people who don't
really mind one way or the other about
them monarchy I think it gets on their
nerves a little bit so it's dangerous I
think dangerous Lambeth Palace is saying
that uh well it's very much an
invitation rather than an expectational
request
yeah I I understand that as well but
it's the same kind of thing I mean do it
do we really need that sort of medieval
kind of on March I mean it used to be
apparently
um I mean I don't know on principle I
never go to coronation so I wasn't that
the last one but apparently the Lords
the members of the House the Lords all
used to line up to say that I mean
that's a bit you know as I say it's all
a bit um
it's sort of a bit tugging the fall look
isn't it I think we're past I think if
Charles wants to make a modern monarchy
um and you know the the Prince of Wales
now William want to have a kind of 21st
century monarchy they need to get past
all that kind of stuff and show show us
how useful they can be in in having a
practical effect on people's everyday
lives yeah well it does talk about a
slim down monarchy so maybe that that
will be one thing that you'd agree with
uh so just finally so you haven't been
invited then
no I haven't been invited I thought my
my running with the queen was quite
interesting she came to a gig of mine
which was interesting where I'd
Rewritten the lyrics to the Ode to Joy
for the reopening the Royal Festival
Hall and afterwards they asked me if I
wanted to stand in the line and shake
hands with her and I suddenly thought to
myself who would pass up the opportunity
to shake hands with a person who gave
the World Cup to Bobby Moore
so I got down there and stood in the
line and the lovely thing was afterwards
I got a message from the palace would it
be possible to get a copy of the score
of the oak to Joy signed by Mr Bragg for
the Royal collection
and you know Mark there's a lot of
people who come to my gigs and hang
around in the foyer afterwards to shake
my hand and get my autograph and I don't
see why I should treat her any different
uh well lovely all right well Billy um
you won't you're not invited I assume
you're not going to be watching it but
listen I'm out of the country actually
Mark I'm out of the country altogether
well listen thank you for coming on
appreciate your time thank you for
having me cheers